here's why morning routines will make  you poor at fragile and weak most people  start doing a routine to feel better and  they feel better in the short term and  then all of a sudden they have to do  that just to feel normal so what that  means is instead of it being a plus it  becomes a crutch and so if as soon as  you have a crutch it means inherently  you have weakness which is why you need  a crutch to begin with and so if you can  eliminate routine as something that you  have to do but something that you choose  to do and can live without meaning if  there's some reason that someday it gets  interrupted you don't say oh my day is  ruined because i couldn't do my morning  routine you have to be a winner  independent of circumstance because i  hope and pray that somebody that i'm  competing against has a crutch and i  know that eventually over a long enough  time horizon that crutch isn't going to  be there and they're going to stumble  and we will be able to crush them